Speaker 1: Welcome to the show. We
have to start today with what could be
a real disaster for Democrats in California in the
California gubernatorial recall election. We've
talked about it a little bit on the bonus show.
And I mean, to bottom line it for you, we could
be looking at Democrats not only losing control
of the governorship in California, but losing
control because of apathetic or apathetic turnout
from Democrats and losing control to an absolutely
radical, destructive, embarrassing Republican
named Larry Elder. And we're going to talk about
that as well. The way that the recall election
works is it's relatively easy to recall a governor
in California, Arnold Schwarzenegger, came to
power and ultimately became governor in California
because of the low bar for a recall of then
Governor Gray Davis. And similarly, the current
recall effort is overwhelmingly being carried
out by Republicans in California. Democrats
have a huge voter registration advantage. And
so when you look at polling, you find that the
it's it's basically 50 50 ish when it comes
to whether in the polling, whether you between
Democrats and Republicans, whether you want to
recall Gavin Newsom, Democrats have a far larger
share of the voters. But the question
is, will they turn up? And it's sort of
a two part election. The first part is, do you
want to recall the governor? If that is a yes,
then who is it that you would like to see become
governor? And Larry Elder is leading in just about
every poll there. I know someone called in last
week and said this guy, Kevin PAF Rath, who I
know a little bit, have been on his show. He's a
YouTube. Kevin PADF Roth is polling first in most
polls I've seen. Kevin, PADF Roth is not polling
first. He's polling a pretty distant second.
And what is really important to understand is
that only 36 percent of all registered voters
want to remove Gavin Newsom. But when you look at
likely voters, it goes up to 47 percent. And this
is that problem I'm talking about when it comes
to the heavily democratic state of California.
Most people want to keep Gavin Newsom. When
you look at only those who are likely to vote,
it's very close to 50/50. And as there's
a good article in The Guardian about this,
apathetic voters could hand California recall
to Republicans, folks seem unaware Gavin Newsom
remains popular, but Democrats appear far less
likely than Republicans to vote in the election
with California's gubernatorial recall election
underway. Newsom is fighting for his political
life. The Democratic governor of a deep blue state
could narrowly lose his seat to a fringe right
wing radio host, in large part due to inertia
and apathy among voters. Democrats outnumber
Republicans nearly two to one in California. But
while the former are distracted and disengaged,
the latter are riled up. Political strategists
and pollsters say by voting at higher rates,
Republicans could capture the governor's seat
for the first time in a decade. And then again,
those numbers I mentioned, only 36 percent
of all registered voters want to oust Newsom,
but that number rises to 47 percent when polling
likely voters. That's a UC Berkeley poll.
A recent CBS News poll found that 72 percent of
Republican voters are very motivated, but only 61
percent of Democrats feel the same. It is really
important to understand that the motivation that
Republicans have comes from hate. It comes from
lies that they've been told and that they believe.
And you only have to look at video from a Larry
Elder event to figure out what is going on. We
played video of this last week. Larry Elder did
an event. He's the Republican leading candidate
for those who want to recall. He's a Republican,
very radical guy. He did an event where he said,
if I am elected governor, I will repeal or ban any
mask or vaccine mandates that are in place at the
time. And the guy got a standing ovation from the
crowd. That's the type of thing that is motivating
the people that want to remove Gavin Newsom. Many
are asking as well, isn't this the exact same
scenario as with Arnold Schwarzenegger? Because
there was a recall done of a Democratic governor,
Democrats maybe assumed we're going to win this
easily because it's California and then Arnold
Schwarzenegger ended up winning. This is a very
different scenario. So although it could be really
bad for Democrats, it's a different situation
than back in the early 2000s. Schwarzenegger
won with 48 percent of the vote and Democrats had
put up like a real candidate, Lieutenant Governor
Bustamante, who got 33 percent. If the 20, 21
Democrats put up and had an actual candidate
running in the recall side, it would. It'll be a
very different scenario now. Kevin PADF breath,
I believe, is running as a Democrat, but really
is is a Republican and is running as a Democrat
for strategic reasons and not a real Democrat
in that sense. And so what you have is the
incumbent Democratic governor simply running
on say no to the recall vote not to remove me,
but if that doesn't happen, it will almost
certainly be radical Republican Larry Elder
who went. So it's just a completely different
scenario. Now, a little bit about Larry Elder,
Larry Elder, to give you a sense of what could end
up taking place if Larry Elder wins. Larry Elder
was a big supporter of Donald Trump. That
should instantly disqualify you, of course,
believes that Donald Trump has nothing, bears no
responsibility for the January 6th Trump riots.
In one of his books, Larry Elder called for
getting rid of the IRS altogether, putting in
place a national sales tax, reducing government by
80 percent, ending welfare, ending entitlements,
getting rid of the minimum wage and getting rid
of corporate taxes. That's his package of economic
ideas that he wrote about some some time ago.
Larry Elder has argued that Roe v. Wade should
be overturned, which would essentially allow
abortion to just be made flat out against the law
has referred to abortion, is murder, has a long
history of tweeting anti LGBT things, published
and gave airtime to serious misinformation and
very fringe views on all sorts of different
science topics. This includes the negative health
effects of smoking, cigarets, climate change,
and, of course, treatments unproven treatments
for covid-19. And I could go on and on and on.
And so the message here is it may be that
because of Democratic apathy in California,
we will have a major loss for the left, which
would be having a state like California with
such a Democratic advantage in terms of party
registration, we could see the Democratic Party
lose a governorship and not only lose it, but
lose it to a wacky right winger like Larry Elder,
because Republicans are far more motivated than
Democrats in California. I've spoken anecdotally,
so, OK, I've spoken to some Democrats in
California who understand what's going on
and planned to vote and are telling people
we've got to get active or we're going to
end up we're going to sleep through a radical
Republican takeover of the state of California.
There are others who have no idea this is
even going on. And that's really the concern.
And the low threshold for doing a recall in
California systemically creates this situation
where you can have a relatively small group
of very motivated and very radical Republicans
overwhelm the will of the state overall, which
is it's a very left leaning state because a
lot of those left leaning people choose not
to vote. So that's a very, very bad thing.
We've got to make sure everybody understands
what's going on. And we'll have more coverage of
the California recall probably next week and
into the recall election in mid-September.